the thing that I I know that myself and
I think Jodi as well is just to not go
backwards meaning is not to not to not
to tread territory that we've already
explored because we're always wanting to
move the characters or grow the
characters I don't wanna say forward but
just to continually growing the
characters so okay Molly on facebook
says what is something that you guys as
cast members would love to see your
characters do in the coming season so
that's quite hard it's really hard and
honestly III then about you guys but I I
rely so much on the writers for that
like III feel like I always come back he
Key's and with an idea of what I don't
want and then I like to see what they
run with and what they create cuz I for
me that's what is really enjoyable about
this whole process is you know a lot of
times you you finish your season you're
like where are we gonna go from here and
then lo and behold you know there is a
APUs ODEs of wonderfulness that that
they they come up with so yeah that's a
tricky question I mean you guys might
have a clear idea of wait where you want
to go I don't know love to look great
and we're great close kenchi there was a
moment there was a moment but I gotta
tell you after that she was attacked
yeah you could have a few of beanies and
parkas and perhaps something a bit more
GG okay and oh yeah this is a really
quick one for you Jody need on Twitter
wants to know if you think the
villanelle will ever use a Scouse accent
on your on the show while you're in
disguise need never we actually season
two it got written in one Episode then I
asked them to take you out because it
just C
too gimmicky for me I was like this is
we know she does accents but scouts felt
a little bit too much of a far stretch
for me yeah like to you know kind of
wink wink to camera so um no I'm afraid
not scouts will not be making an
appearance I'm kidding me
so hopefully and hoping I would slip
into scholars at any point that's the
aim okay this is a question from Laura
on Twitter and hers is about music
actually so when we need the scene the
dancing scene was the music that was
played was that in the show that we see
is that the music there was actually
that was actually played it was it was
we had it on the scene and it created
such a gorgeous atmosphere like I
remember walking into the Bessette and
and and the essays were practicing their
kind of dance you know to see where they
would be fit around us and and the music
was on and it was like so overwhelming I
don't know I had like took a deep breath
when we went in there it felt you know
it's a pivotal moment in the story and
it just felt so cathartic I don't know
it was really lovely and it was nice to
have it as well for our rhythm and I've
got a music question is what is some
what is filling our listening to when
she leaves her family scene and she's
sitting on the train in her slightly
overdone denim yeah we we actually had
speakers and we played Crocodile Rock
and I was alright I mean that's what she
would have definitely been listening to
so yeah we kind of blasted that on the
on the train okay great okay and I have
a couple here which is um when you you
just mentioned something before journey
which I thought was quite interesting
which is what you said that you that you
know where you don't want your courage
to get to go so what what have
you said in the past and what would you
say about season four and that's all of
you where was you know I think for me
it's just important that the that she
evolves you know I I feel like what what
was flashy and surprising about season
lon
over time you know you you it was and um
people get used to it and they expect
you know what's common and I'm actually
now what is most surprising is you know
for instance like you know villanelle
letting the little boy live and letting
him go see Elton John like you know
there was that would never be surprising
at at one stage so I think it's it's
just navigating that and you know and
and the kind of opulence and and the
wealth and and the clothes were so
important to her and beginning and and
now I feel like her priorities a shift
in in different ways or at least her
focus is in a different direction and I
just like that with each season we kind
of rain check and go over it and see
just listen to what it is that the
characters are actually saying and and
and then you know and pick make sure we
pick up from there and and continue on
to the next the next chapter okay it's
that I mean we've mentioned clothes
Sandra but is there any way that you
don't want Eve to go presumably back to
a chicken
I don't assume she wants to go back
there no I need it for keeping her out
from the chicken you know I actually
just add to what Jody is saying you know
when these are all kind of intricate
nuanced performances that are coming
from very very like deep emotional
landscapes the thing that I I know that
myself and I think Jody as well is just
to not go backwards meaning is not to
not to not to tread territory that we've
already explored because we're always
wanting to move the characters or grow
the
wanna sit forward but just to
continually growing the characters so
that it would that really gives the
writers such an interesting challenge
you know because it's like okay now
before there was you know a cat and cat
or cat mouse or cat and cat kind of
dynamic now that in some ways at the
very end at the bridge I feel like they
turned to each other and understand like
each other is the only one that it can
really trust where you then go
emotionally in character wise from there
is is is very very exciting that's where
I you I do want them to go Suzanne you
got to unmute yourself for that one any
thoughts about series four well you know
it's I know the position Laura is in
right now
so I would never want to add to the
noise of you know distill what she's
doing I will say obviously you know
Laura Neil who's doing season four she
wrote on season three and she's
brilliant and hilarious and yes she's
got like the most amazing imagination of
mine so it'll be unsurprising you know
whatever comes we'll be like I don't
mean unsurprising I mean like it'll be
vivid and wild and crazy and surprising
whatever she comes up with but I just
think the challenge that any writer has
in that position it's just that you
remain true to the world and the
characters and yet you take it somewhere
new and that involves taking risks which
is scary because you know people know
what they like about the show and what
they love and when you try new things
you know that involves risk but actually
sort of alluding to what Joe D saying as
well you know we'd like Bill amel and
evolving that the things that people
kind of associate with her
you just can't tread water and I think
that's what the show has done so well
and and I know in Laura's hands will
continue to do is just you know break
new ground with the characters so that's
what's exciting about going forward but
it's you know that is the challenge of
the
really yeah it's great okay so look I
have um because we're coming up to the
end of our lovely chat I would like to
ask you all do you can you give us a
favorite moment and this is all four of
you it's a favorite moment from the last
series either on screen or in filming or
just a moment that you that you
remembered and enjoyed who wants to go
first
I will Andrew does when we were shooting
the bus scene and it's a fight
George OD you know on something that's
not to say it's like yeah yeah so Eve is
so seeing gone now that she it goes
forward and attacks her and so you know
Judy and I are going through fight moves
that you know we have our choreographer
to fight the stunt coordinator there to
teach us and so we're going we're going
this was a take though right yeah use it
but you know they probably cut the sound
up and so but there was this one moment
where um where I actually connected with
with Jodi like I connected with her body
not in a in a terrible way at all but I
connected with her and I said like
fighting right and and and then we
continued on with the scene I remember
Jodi afterwards you were like that was
the most Eve thing possible yeah because
it was just genius it was like she hit
me and then she like came back and she
was like I'm sorry and then Rick what
about you JD what's your favorite moment
from the last series and me I think I
really enjoyable moment for me was
working with Shannon Murphy as the
director of block 5 & 6 and I think
because like Suzanne was sayin it was
such a delicate episode and as we all
know that they were every director every
person brings their own energy but a
director kind of sets the tone for the
two episodes and she kind of came in and
just really encouraged me and in a way
and I think which I think I really
needed for the kind of that that episode
and that was an a really enjoyable
experience for me like we were in
Romania for two weeks I think in the
middle of the mountains which was
beautiful and very surreal but it was
very kind of a massive and it was it was
a very fun that was a very fun
experience I also loved my favorite
moment from the show though is the bath
scene with Fiona and Sandra that's my
favorite moment from from this season
yeah meetings were every like what about
I think my favorite moment was I I was
in the bath and it was a very deep
birthday to him I'm putting water in and
I thought was very Carolyn that at the
end I asked for a talent that I would
just stand up so I stood up and I was
naked and the whole camera crew nearly
fell off their cameras I was really
hoping they'd keep it in I don't mean
they would just get the whole pillow
they nearly died and that was very good
and what about you Suzanne I mean given
you know this is a challenge you were
given that you know the whole of the
series three I can't imagine what you
felt like at the beginning and now it's
at the end what was your favorite moment
it's so hard it's like choosing your
favorite child you know there's so many
you love for different reasons I mean
there are moments that I have to say the
bus scene actually is one of those very
rare moments where it's exactly as I
imagined it and that doesn't happen I
mean often it's like better or just
different but like when I saw it I was
like it was as if my brain had been put
on the screen
the energy of it you know this detail
obviously about that they worked out it
was different but just the energy of
that scene I was as exciting as it kind
of you know when we were thinking about
and
yeah I actually I'm picking loads now so
just the poignancy of eve and Kenny's
last scene there was something in that
that you know if she now knows it's
their last moment together but there was
something in that that I just I thought
was so moving and Carolyn and Kenny's
last scene actually got both of those
were just so moving to me yeah can I
just say as well son remember when we
did this scene with all of us we shot it
for like two days in Paul's house I mean
you were sat on the sofa and we were
watching Fiona and Kim we're watching
their play for like a day for days great
memory as well yeah yeah you two set
together like it's slightly like naughty
schoolgirls after this yeah well you got
on with the business of just blown
people away you know yeah you know who
it is you know it were a nightmare on
the sofa the two of them they just kept
on commenting and somehow we knew okay
and I'd like to say and we've got to
come to the end of our lovely chat but I
would really like to say it's been um
it's been a really great way to spend an
early Friday evening and it's not quite
like that for you Sundra but I mean
fantastic
you know lockdown can be pretty rubbish
but this is really great and I'd like to
say thank you to everybody who tuned in
you're all across the world on on zoom
in on face thank you appreciate it
yeah and obviously we'll all be tuning
into the next killing Eve when it
happens and but thank you all for
bringing such a great series and such
great characters to us all because we
really love them baby in the bin killing
people standing up naked standing up we
love you all
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]